- So, Dean, what's something
no one knows about George
if you were gonna tell us that?
- He don't have social media, do ya?
- You don't have social media?
- No, I don't.
- How do you get away with that?
- I just never had it.
I had Facebook at school,
and then, I wasn't using
it so I got rid of it,
and then, I remember when Twitter started.
I remember my friend came round,
he was like, have you seen this?
It's basically like Facebook statuses,
but you can read celebrities'
Facebook statuses.
And I don't know, okay.
And I just never, I never got on it,
so I've, but maybe it's a good thing,
'cause I've just, I've seen
some of those selfies there.
(laughing)
- Would you let your
parents take over your
well, not yours.
Would you let?
You don't have one, but
if you did have one,
would you let your parents take over?
- Not in a million years.
- You don't think it'd be funny?
- No.
I don't know what they'd post.
That'd be the worst
thing ever, wouldn't it?
- The unknown.
- I feel like my mother
would be hilarious.
Like it would just be random things
that she didn't realize she posted it,
and it would be great.
I feel like it's something
I'm gonna do on Mother's Day.
I'm gonna have her take
over my social media.
- Yeah, you should.
- Yes.
It's gonna be just chaos.
- And she wouldn't know that she posted,
I remember my mum, my dad,
the first camera phone
that he had, my mum looked
at it the wrong way around,
she went oh my God, there's a camera,
and she looked down the lens like
(laughing)
- She was like I've got
it, I've almost got it.
- It's all black, I can't see anything.
- [Kelly] Something's
wrong with this phone.